let's break down the Advent 22 Lena the
plug cuck situation their two podcasts
or slash porn stars they're married and
they host this podcast no jumper where
they talk to their guests and then they
plow their guests at the end not to be
braggy here but one time we were
recording a podcast and they were next
door recording a podcast and we heard
them clapping cheeks and uh yeah I
learned a lot anyways Adam 22 is now
facing major backlash after he revealed
that he let another dude cork Lena's
cooch then after that Adam was like you
know what dude Lina getting railed has
been so good for her career and I'm so
psyched that she got creampied by Jason
and the rest of the world was like bro
what the are you talking about and
then after that he's like dude honestly
like she's a good sport like she's
watched me go to the Bone Zone with like
hundreds of chicks and I was like why
are you Tweeting this dude then on their
podcast Lena admitted that she enjoyed
Jason's hog because it's bigger and
while she was saying this Adam stared
straight at the wall so the end I just
want to say I'm very very stoked for all
parties involved Nina enjoyed herself
and Adam is a very